we're days away from the end of Obama's
presidency which I don't know if you
guys are aware we're getting a new
president pretty soon now you guys don't
pay attention to the news but but what's
Hussein in the membrane got planned now
and he won't be busy pardoning turkeys
24/7 well according to Billboard Obama
made an offhand remark to the ambassador
at a Sweden that he's still waiting for
his job at Spotify the well-known
streaming service that informs your
friends you were listening to Papa Roach
all day well Obama's quip inspired
Spotify CEO Daniel Elk to tweet hey
Barack Obama I heard you're interested
in a role in Spotify have you seen this
one and it wasn't just him pointing at
his dick although that would have been
hilarious it was actually a job listing
for president of playlists right here oh
we're having lots of fun makes you
forget for a second the next Secretary
of Defense is probably gonna be why
Luigi so comedians comedians in case the
Spotify gig doesn't work out what's
another tech job Obama might consider
after office if he I think is going to
bring hope and change to the street five
videos on WorldStarHipHop yes boys boys
painting I know about Obama but Biden's
got a job moderating the all-natural
milfs uh Beretta okay points yeah
all-natural Flula a president of tinder
because he's used to dealing with dicks
all day